[APPLAUSE].
>> WELCOME TO ANOTHER EPISODE OF
APOCALYPSE NEVER.
[LAUGHTER].
WILL HERE AT THIS MOMENT IS VERY
DANGEROUS MOMENT, BECAUSE OF
DOLDRUMS IMPULSES.
>> WE ARE AT THE EARLY STAGES OF
THE HOT WORK.
IT IS A MONUMENTAL MOMENT.
>> THIS IS ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
IT IS GOING TO GROSS IN THAT
REGION IN A WAY THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY WHY NOT AFFORD.
>> WAR AND AROUND HIS MEDICINE
IS STRATEGICALLY AND MORALLY A
DISASTER.
>> THAT WOULD HAVE WIDENED AND
EXPLODED MIDDLE EAST INTO A WAR
THAT LIKE WE HAVE NURSING
PRINTED >> THAT STRIKE HAS
PREDICTABLY WITHIN!
, KICKED THE HORNETS NEST IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
ONE CONVULSION OF CHOCOLATES.
YOU WILL SO READY FOR
ARMAGEDDON.
BECAUSE THEN IT WOULD ALL BE IN
TOP.
I SEEN THAT MUCH WISHFUL
THINKING SINCE MICHAEL MOORE
TRIED A LEATHER PANTS.
[LAUGHTER].
BUT AS USUAL, THE END TO THE
RAIN CHECK.
BUMMER.
THEY JUST INSULTED FROM BETH AND
HIS FOLLOW-UP SANDRA BRADY AND
CHRIS CUOMO, JUST START ALL OF
HIS MATE REMITTING BOTOX IN HIS
FACE.
BUT DID THAT TOP STOP THE STUPID
HELLO.
IN AN EFFORT TO MAINTAIN THE
ANTITRUST NARRATIVE, ONE
COMPARED TO LOAN MONEY TO LADY
GUY.
>> PRINCES BY AND IT.
>> WOULD PRINCE ONSET DIANA
DIED.
THERE WAS A HUGE OUTPOURING.
ELVIS PRESLEY TWO.
IT TURNS OUT THAT HIS BELOVED.
AN NEAR INDIAN PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE GET DEPICTION OF
THEM.
IT'S AN COMING UP.
THERE IS NO AMERICAN EMOTION IN
THIS.
BUT NO MOTION OF GENOCIDE.
>> OH MY GOD.
LET A GUY, ELVIS.
I THINK THIS IS BEEN SMELLING TO
ME PARTS.
BACK IN THE ONE IS YOU BETTER
NOT GO THAT WENT OUT BECAUSE YOU
BECOME AWARE.
GASTRONOMIC OF THE ONLY THING A
GREAT LETTERS BECOME LOCAL
PAPER, >> WOULD PROBLEM.
[LAUGHTER].
SO HERE IS THAT THERE IS GOING
TO BLOW YOUR MIND.
TWICE WOULD TRUMP USES ANY OF
COURSE, HIS SCOPE METS.
EVEN THE NEW YORK TIMES,
MILITARY OF COURSE, SINCE JAMIE
CARTER WHY.
THE MEDIA CONSPIRACY AMPLIFIES
BECAUSE IT IS SO FAIR.
SO WHAT HAPPENS, HAVE TO IT FOR
ALL IT'S WORTH.
I GET IT.
I DID THE SAME THING WAS HERE,
WOULD I GET A LITTLE DRUNK.
[LAUGHTER].
MAKE A HUGE DEAL OUT OF IT.
IN THE NEVER GET THE CHANCE
AGAIN.
[LAUGHTER].
SO MAYBE IT WILL TAKE ANY CHANCE
TO CULT PROBABLY FASCIST.
YOU CAN READ BE PRAYING
PASSENGER PLANE IN THE MEDIA THE
BLAME, TRUMP.
IRAN'S NOT EVEN BLAMING HIM.
BUT SHE IS.
>> WHAT IS PROJECTED IS TRUE,
THIS IS YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE FROM THE
ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN AND
PROVOCATIVE WAY BY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> A NUDGE IN IT IS LIKE THIS
AFTER PEARL HARBOR.
NOW MAYBE IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE ALL
OF THE SHINY BOATS OUT THERE,
WHICH ARE USED FOR WAR, THIS
WOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED.
IT'S FUN WATCHING TOM OF COURSE
DEMOCRATS TO DEFEND STUFF NO
ACTUAL HUMAN WOULD DEFEND.
HERE'S THE VIEWPOINT WHITE
RACIST A LOVE THAT.
[LAUGHTER].
MA START THANKS.
HERE WE ARE APPLAUDING MIGHT
MAKE IT.
THESE NOW THEY POSTED TRUMP.
>> SOME GOOD NEWS, ANYTHING
ITEMS.
MEMBER RICHARD SPENCER, THE
WHITE NATIONALIST GROUP THAT WAS
MARCHING IN CHARLOTTESVILLE IN
NEW ORLEANS FOR TRUMP RATED NOT
ANYMORE.
HE TWEETED THIS TIME.
BRODY AND MONEY FOR DONALD TRUMP
IN 2016 PRINT.
[APPLAUSE].
>> THEY ARE UP A BOOK IS THE
PREMISE DOES.
IT ONLY A TINY THING JOY NOTICE
WAS A RAIN.
[LAUGHTER].
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE MUSIC
ALONG TRIBUTE AND FREE.
A WEENIE.
[LAUGHTER].
THEN SLID CHOOSING POLYP TAKES
OVER MINERALOGY.
FROM WINCING IN EPSTEIN AND
CLINTON AND EVERY PIG GETS A
TAG.
AND NOW SOME NEW MURDEROUS
GENERALS.
MISSILES INCHES SPACE, SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN AN AMERICAN BASE AND
EQUIPMENT.
AND THEN THEY CAN A NUMBER.
AND THEY CALLED IT TO THE
KILLING OF THE TOP GENERAL.
A NUDGE IN THAT, IT'S LIKE THE
DELIBERATELY WHIPPED AND TRY TO
AROUND THE BASES LIKE THEY WILL
FUND.
SO IF YOU ARE SO MONIES, YET BE
PASSED.
THAT IS ENOUGH.
IT IS A WEIRD MESSAGE FROM
AREND.
HE GOT RID OF THE GUY WAS A PAIN
IN THE NECK TO PRETTY GRANTED
PUTTING OUT YOUR CAR GOT STOLEN
MZ KEEPS KEYNOTE CARLA.
I'M TRYING DO YOU GET RID OF IT
FOR YEARS WE PARKED IT IN THE
BACK IN WITH KEYS IN THE
IGNITION, THAT WAS ALL MONEY.
[LAUGHTER].
SORRY MEDIA, A SNEAK THINKER.
WAR WAS IN OPERATION DIGIT, IT
WAS MORE LIKE OPERATION DESERT
CRASH.
THE PRESS CONFERENCE LASTED
LONGER.
I WOULDN'T, SHOULD THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL AND
HAPPY BUT NO AMERICANS ARE
HARMED.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, SHOULD
BE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL AND HAPPY.
NO AMERICANS WILL HARMED.
MOST NIGHTS ATTACK BY THE
RADIANT REGIME.
>> IS HE GOOD OUTCOME.
COURSES PRODUCE, DIDN'T GIVE
THEM A HEADS UP.
DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO CALL IT
MESSY.
NOT OPERATING WITH A FULL DECK.
.
[SCREAMING].
WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO CALL IT
NIPSEY.
NOT PARTNERING WITH A FALSE
BACK.
[LAUGHTER].
>> THAT WOULD YOU TELL SHIP
REALLY IS HE BIG LIQUOR.
SPEAK.
>> SHIP IS HE BIG LIQUOR.
SAY HOW YOU DOING.
LISTEN WE HAVE THE WORLD NEWS
NUMBER ONE TERRORIST.
WE GOT THEM LINED UP AT THEM.
THERE WILL OPEN SELECT.
YOU LITTLE PENCIL NECK.
>> NO ONE WANTS WORK.
WHAT WE SAW THE WE ARE STUCK IN
A PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
WEDNESDAY TO DO NOTHING IN
BETWEEN HIS PRESENCE IS THE TURF
THE TRAMP NEVER USE OF OPEN
BETWEEN NOTHING AND EVERYTHING.
TRUMP SHOWS, DECISIVE ACTION TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS.
NOT BAD, BUT THEN AGAIN HE
ALWAYS SAID HE BE MORE
PRESIDENTIAL.
>> I WILL I WOULD SAY THAT I CAN
BE MORE PRESIDENTIAL THAN ANY
OTHER CANDIDATE.
MAYBE ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
[LAUGHTER].
OH MY.
[APPLAUSE].
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT NEWS
GUEST, HE'S IS AN AMERICAN IS
THE PRESIDENTS' DAY METRO
CELEBRATED.
[APPLAUSE].
NEWS IN THE FBI NEWS LEAST
WANTED LIST.
HER LEFT IS CONTAGIOUS WAS THERE
WAS A COP.
AND THEY GOT A HERNIA.
HERE WE COME.
[APPLAUSE].
PETE, WHAT YOU THINK THIS WEEK.
PULLING OUT.
DO THINGS DONE, OVER.
WE THINK.
>> OF COURSE HAS BROUGHT DONE.
BECAUSE OF ONSET DONE.
THEIR ENTIRE REGIME IS PREMISED
ON EXPLORERS TERRACE.
THEY'RE NOT A GRID OF THE CAN'T
LIVE THAT WENT OUT IT.
>> I WAS IN FAVOR OF HONESTLY, A
MUCH STRONGER STRONG NEWS
STRIKES.
THEY ARE GOING TO PRETTY CAN'T
LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE THEY HAVE
A GOOD BOMBS.
NO TIME TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP.
>> REALLY.
>> GOOD FOR HIM, I TRUST AND
SUPPORT HIM BECAUSE IT'S THE
SAME REASON WHITE YOU SUPPORTED
AND TRUSTED RONALD REAGAN.
YOU KNOW IS CORE AND WHAT HE
BELIEVES.
AND HE HAS THE DEFENSE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE) YOU WOULD NEVER
BELIEVE THAT A BARACK OBAMA OR
JAMIE CARTER.
IN THIS CASE, YOU KNOW TRUMP AT
THE END OF THE DAY IS GOING HAVE
A RETROSPECT.
THIS THE RIGHT, DO IT.
AND RHINOS.
YOU TAKE ONE MORE DROP AMERICAN
WE'LL HAVE, YOU'VE DONE.
[APPLAUSE].
AGAINST WILL RENEW, BUT WHO KNEW
THE DEMOCRATS HATED AMERICA THIS
MUCH.
THE PEOPLE TO KILL, IT WOULD-BE
LIKE, CONTROL AND AND YET, THIS
HAS BROUGHT GOOD ENOUGH.
>> JOE, I LOVE WATCHING TRUMP
DEFENDING WHERE STUFF.
AND UPON LIKE RICHARD SPENCER.
THE WHITE SUPREMACIST.
WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT THAT.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE
LADIES OF THE VIEW BECAUSE EVERY
COMING TO THE SHOW, AND
TERRIFIED THAT IS GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING STUPID ABOUT POLITICS.
THERE ARE QUITE SCUM.
THEY DO SOMETHING STUPID
EVERYDAY.
[APPLAUSE].
OF THE PART WITH AGO, THAT IS
REALLY GOOD AND THEY STOPPED AND
SAID INTERESTING.
THEY WERE ON BOARD.
MAYBE WILL BE GUEST ON THE VIEW.
INTIMACY.
GREAT.
WE WILL MOVE ON THEN.
WHAT IS YOUR ANALYSIS CAT
ANALYSIS.
>> I WAS SEVEN.
LAST WEEK, I WAS ONE PERSON THE
CATCHER SAID THAT I DID HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THIS WHOLE
THING.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYTHING IS JUST
FINE.
[LAUGHTER].
I'M HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
SO THE INTERESTING THING IS A
LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE LEFT, THE
THINK THEY CAN SAY THAT.
THEY'RE DISAPPOINTED THAT IT
DIDN'T GO WELL.
ON THE ONE HAND I GET IT, WOULD
SOMEONE HURTS YOU, PROVIDE COME,
YOU DON'T WANT THEM TO
ACCOMPLISH THINGS AND BE HAPPY.
WHENEVER I HEAR THAT MY
EX-BOYFRIEND IS COMEDY SHOW, I
WANT HIM TO DO TERRIBLY.
[LAUGHTER].
BUT IF I KNEW IN HIM DO
TERRIBLY, BUT THAT THERE
WOULD-BE LIKE THIS HUGE WAR
THOUGH THESE INNOCENT PEOPLE
BEING PULLED UP, LIKE I WOULD
THINK ABOUT IT.
BUT ULTIMATELY I WOULD DECIDE
LIKE NOW, WHAT EVERYBODY TO
LIVE.
I WANTED TO DO WELL.
BUT THEY WERE ALL OF US LIKE
DISAPPOINTED.
THEY WANTED TO JUST BE LIKE A
HOT SEE I TOLD YOU.
BUT THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT IT
WOULD EVEN BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
MOMENT OF GLOATING BECAUSE THEY
WOULD-BE BLOWN UP.
[LAUGHTER].
>> THAT'S TRUE.
[APPLAUSE].
>> I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY IN
DEFE FIELD, I DON'T
THINK SHE CLEARED THAT
CONVERSATION WITH WHOOPI
GOLDBERG BEFORE SHE DROPPED IT.
[LAUGHTER].
BECAUSE IF YOU WATCH THE BODY
LANGUAGE, WILL BE WAS LIKE BUT,
DO HATED THAT MUCH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP LOST SUPPORT
THE WHITE SUPREMACIST, THAT
ACTUALLY WHEREBY, PLEASES ME.
[LAUGHTER].
MEANS HE'S DONE SOMETHING
NONRACIST.
FOR THE ARE LIKE THE HELP WITH
THIS, HOW IS THAT.
HOW IS THAT A GOOD.
THEY SIDED WITH RACIST.
>> SOMEBODY ON THEIR WOULD'VE
SAID IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MS. BECAME SAFE, ISN'T THAT A
GOOD THING.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK ON THE
COMMERCIAL SHE WOULD-BE THERE.
[LAUGHTER].
IS THAT THE RIGHTISTS RACIST
THING.
>> THAT IS THE MIC.
IT IS LITERALLY, AMERICA, THE
WORLD IS SO AFRAID OF HER CRAZY
PRESIDENT, THEN HE WILL KILL
YOUR GENERAL AND GET BACK, HE HE
WILL BLOW UP THE PARKING LOT BUT